hello to Mr Flynn it's good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program why
was this the right time for her to go
morning Keith um I think Nicola made
clear yesterday that of course the the
challenges of high office unless we
forget that Nicola has been a captain
secretary the deputy first Minister and
the the first Minister itself over the
course of the the last 16 years has
taken its talk and I like everyone in
the SMP
um but Nicholas uh taking this decision
which has been a formidable leader of
our formidable leader in the Scottish
government as she did yesterday
throughout her tenure she approached her
resignation speech was that typical
empathy worms and humility that's came
to personify for for a leadership of the
Scottish government and you know she's
been in a personal inspiration to me and
so many others so it's been a sad thing
to see her take this decision but I
entirely understand her reasons for
doing so
yeah hastily abandoned the party after
mistakes of her own making is what I was
reading the newspaper this morning
um a good day for unionism
well I you know I'm a journalist and I
appreciate my colleagues in print him
and if you don't
um they say that well there were
mistakes we were making how do you
regroup from this
I I don't think it's necessarily a case
of regrouping we're an incredibly strong
position we're obviously pulling
exceptionally well in Scotland as a
party we know that in terms of
Independence the numbers uh tend to
fluctuate between 50 and 50 uh just
above 50 and just below 50 which I think
is incredibly positive we've had a very
successful Scottish local elections last
year where I think we've got a record
number uh of councilor so the party's in
an incredibly strong position and more
important than that we've got an
exceptional bunch of msps and Hollywood
one of whom will now become the leader
of the SMP and indeed the the leader of
the the Scottish government I think
that's quite an exciting thing and I
look forward to them setting up their
agenda and uh and taking the party
forward do you acknowledge it's a good
day for unionism
hey I I'm not really focused on unionism
if I'm honest uh like I said I think the
Scottish national party isn't an
incredibly strong position and whether
you've listed a number of names the
others the some others who I'm sure May
well be considering putting themselves
forward to be the the next leader of the
party and you know these are focused and
incredible abundance of experience also
like Nikola excellent communicators and
I have no doubt that we are going to be
in a strong position going forward and
that's that's where my focus
understandably lies okay yeah it's no
the time for the SMP potentially to make
their case less about independence and
more about domestic policy
I don't think we've done anything but
make our case about independence based
upon domestic policy because if you look
at many of the challenges that exist
within Society at this moment so the
pressures on our NHS much of that is
born directly from the fact that we are
struggling to recruit people in Social
care as a result of leaving the European
Union obviously problems that were made
by the UK government not the Scottish
government so no matter which way you
look at things in terms of the
challenges we face I firmly believe that
we could do things much better if we had
the full powers of an independent nation
so the two things the domestic
challenges and indeed Independents are
and are interlinked and will continue to
make that case to the Scottish people 25
people a week losing their lives to a
drug death
um the latest figures coming out later
on this year I mean that's not down to
um leaving the European unionism
no it's it's not um and many of those
challenges are born from one of the
cities where I grew up
um which is something which is
incredibly tough to take these are these
are generational problems Kate and
there's quite clearly been generational
issues in Scotland in relation to dogs
indeed with alcohol the Scottish
government's obviously for a significant
amount of funding in relation to the
dog's challenges it stands there's a
task force which was set off I know
there's a uh a particular Minister who's
tasked in the Scottish government was
trying to to overcome these problems and
we are all focused on overcoming these
problems but these are generational
issues and I think everyone is very well
aware of that in Scotland
Nicola sturgeon said that she will stay
on in Parliament will she not be a
distraction by doing that
no I think that's entirely the the right
thing to do and the clusterogene is an
incredibly experienced leader as I've
already highlighted and I think it's
it's a good thing I think the people of
Scotland will be quite comforted by the
fact that she'll be there holding
holding the reins for the for the coming
weeks whilst the parties selects a new
leader in a new and a new first Minister
and let's not escape from the fact that
there is ongoing big challenges to come
and making sure that there is that that
continuity at the top is very important
you've said that you won't stand as the
next leader who are you back in
uh yeah Dita I'll not be standing
um of course
um the the next leader of Scottish
national party needs to have the ability
to be first Minister and no MP has the
ability to be first Minister for all
these reasons that we're located in
London and not Edinburgh in terms of who
I'm back and I've not seen anyone's with
our name into the into the right yet
once names start going into that right
now I'll have conversations with my
colleagues see what their policy
priorities are in terms of immediate
challenges that that we Face how they
intend to overcome uh some of the the
issues in relation to the economy in
relation to the Health Service and
relations the cost of living cases and
indeed our Energy Future and of course
how they set out their Pathway to to
that independent future and I'm looking
forward to that positive that positive
discussion once my colleagues decide
whether they want to put themselves
forward or not yeah you did say that it
was a party of until riches who would
you like to see uh put their names
forward
I think it would be unfair of Me Kate
particularly given what the first
Minister said in terms of the the
pressures of office and the toll it can
take to put additional pressure onto
someone when they're probably having
discussions with their nearest and
dearest at the moment as to whether they
stand or not and so I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna put an additional layer of
pressure on to any particular uh
individual but what I will do is
obviously speak with them uh all uh I
have indeed there is more than one who
puts himself forward to be the leader of
the party and engage with them to see
and what their policy priorities are and
their values come forward
do you still think that the next
election should be a de facto referendum
on Independence
I actually think it's there so the party
um was intending on having a conference
on the 19th of March to outline uh the
next stage for us in terms of what comes
next because obviously we've been told
by the UK Supreme Court that we don't
have the powers to hold an independence
despite the repeated mandates that
Nicola Sterling in the party have won a
numerous Scottish elections
um so we need to chart that next course
how do we get to that independent future
now the fact to referendum is obviously
put forward by the by the Foster and we
were going to be discussing in debate in
the merits of at that party conference I
I personally think that party conference
should be paused for obvious reasons I
think the new leader should have the the
opportunity and they need the space to
set out their position their values and
their intentions going forward and so
that would be my take in relation to
that key I think it's sensible that we
do hit the pause button on on that
conference and allow the new leader the
opportunity to set up their Vision but
in answer to my question do you think
the next election should be a de facto
referendum
like I say I think it's important that
the the new leader uh and there will be
a new leader has given me opportunity to
clearly set out their platform and we
know that it was Nicole sturgeon's
preference to have a de facto referendum
indeeds it was my preference as well
um but I'm not going to time buying the
hands of any potential successor I think
it's important that we have
um or we allow them the opportunity to
set out their intentions uh in due
course and and I'll listen to what they
have to say closely
good to talk to you thanks very much and
you for joining us on the program this
morning thank you thanks a lot thanks